[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com for months i've been talking
about what seems to be kind of a
pressing desire from donald trump to
bomb North Korea because it would really
serve so many purposes that to trump
according to Trump's own internal logic
would be really important bombing North
Korea might make Trump seem strong and
powerful and it would prove that he has
the biggest button I think is what he
used to refer to take attention away
from the scandals right the lack of
accomplishments of the Trump
administration and then on some level a
nation at war at least initially right
in the long term it didn't quite work
out for george w bush but at least
initially a nation at war
whatever that even means in 2017 often
will rally behind the president which
might help donald trump's
approval rating woes which are not going
away but he hasn't done it yet right
donald trump hasn't yet struck North
Korea and we may now be learning why
because according to new reports in the
Telegraph and The Wall Street Journal
it's been Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson and Secretary of Defense Jim
mattis who have been urging Trump not to
strike North Korea something that by all
accounts he has wanted to do 100% as we
imagined was going was going on in his
mind and interestingly these reports say
that Donald Trump's national security
adviser I like to call him the not yet
indicted Michael Flynn HR McMaster he
reportedly is in favor of striking North
Korea he wanted to do what's called a
bloody nose strategy that means that
when North Korea does one of their
typical provocations you immediately and
sharply lash out in violence and the
analogy of calling it a bloody nose
strategy is you punch someone in the
nose immediately when they insult you
for exam
to show them that you're not going to be
pushed around or something like that I
guess and these reports also are
renewing allegations that Rex Tillerson
approach is really not pleasing Trump
very much and there's every indication
that Rex Tillerson is still on thin ice
we recently heard there was a CNN
interview I saw a few days ago where one
out analyst said a Tillerson is not
going to last through 2018 now Tillerson
when asked said he has no plans to leave
but saying I have no plans to leave is
different than I can guarantee you I
won't be fired but that's sort of a
sidebar to what we're talking about here
which is North Korea
the truth is Tillerson and Jim mattis
are correct to be cautious because in
the end North Korea does have nuclear
weapons whether they are telling the
truth or not that they could strike the
u.s. or US assets or US allies it's
actually kind of irrelevant because the
possibility is there for them to strike
someone with their news and that's not
something that the United States wants
to provoke or be connected to being the
catalyst for and Secretary of Defense
Jim mattis believes and I agree with him
that if Kim jong-un did a retaliation
the likes of which he'd be capable of
doing
somewhere right not necessarily on US
soil but somewhere that it would be
quote a war more serious in terms of
human suffering than anything we've seen
since 1953 with a potential death toll
in the millions
imagine the dynamic in the White House
right I and again I happen to agree with
Tillerson and mattis a strike is a bad
idea for a number of reasons but there's
a case to be made for HR McMasters
position reasonable people competent
people people that are fit to serve and
make these types of decisions they could
have a reasonable conversation about
what the right approach with with North
Korea is but it's not like Trump is
sitting there with these guys
participating in the discussions like a
dud like an adult I imagine Pat that
Trump is sitting there while Tillerson
and mattis are arguing against a strike
and McMaster is outlining the possible
benefits I imagine Trump sitting there
with a TV remote in his hand
watching Fox and Friends saying yeah
let's do it let's bond them give me the
button to press guys yeah that imagine
he's leaning towards McMasters side but
it is interesting how Tillerson and
mattis one year into the presidency have
become the voices of reason here I mean
neither are progressive champions to say
the least you know it's probably best
that they stay in this administration
and further the idea of Tillerson as
someone in a cabinet is absolutely
horrifying in terms of what it means
about the kleptocracy right you're
talking about a lifelong oil executive
whose philosophy much like Trump's has
been self enrichment and greed and doing
what's best for him no matter who he has
to receive a medal from in the case of
Vladimir Putin the fact that someone
like that we say this is one of the more
reasonable voices I don't want to
normalize Tillerson but it's true
compared to Trump he is more reasonable
CEO of ExxonMobil who's probably only
put in there in the first place to
secure that five hundred billion dollar
oil Hjorth Russia or or whatever other
one of his different deals that he had
on the table was was attractive to Trump
this is all very scary news right the
the news that the president is this
interested and this focused on striking
North Korea is not good it's a strike
that would be of questionable benefit to
anybody meaning it's unclear if we did a
strike like this what the benefit is to
us or to our allies or to the civilians
of North Korea who I guess are we still
claiming Pat that we want to do what's
best for the civilians we are Korea I
mean Trump I guess is sort of saying
that but I don't know that anybody
really believes that and we've now
learned and I guess this is in the world
of really blasted silver linings I guess
it's good that there's someone trying to
prevent Trump from striking North Korea
haphazardly although it's unclear
whether they're going to be effective
over the long term not good
erratic irrational I don't know what
other adjectives I would assign to it
let's talk a little bit about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and golden
boy son-in-law of Donald Trump Jared
Kushner husband of Ivanka Trump to reset
the back story for you on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in case
you've forgotten Trump campaigned on I'm
gonna solve the israeli-palestinian
conflict
and you at the time might have wondered
wait people who actually know about the
conflict and understand the conflict
have been unable to solve the conflict
why is it Donald Trump who knows nothing
about it is going to be able to solve it
well part of trumps reasoning was that
Jared Kushner his son-in-law and
ambassador David Friedman were going to
be able to solve the entire thing now
the reality has been the exact opposite
of that Jared Kushner completely
incompetent data Friedman the last
person who should be involved in that
discussion he actually said at one point
that he believes there should be more
Israeli settlements and was a very loud
voice in the push for moving the US
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem in
recognizing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel all terrible ideas and from very
early on in this administration Jared
Kushner was involved in shaping policy
around the Middle East related to the
israeli-palestinian conflict in fact
when Trump went on that first
now-infamous diplomatic trip to Israel
and other parts of the Middle East Jared
Kushner was right there because he was
Trump's guy I guess in the area we've
now learned through very good reporting
by the New York Times that just before
that trip right just before Jared
Kushner went with Donald Trump to the
Middle East to be involved in
negotiating American policy there
Kushner's family real estate company
received thirty million dollars from
menorah MIFF Tajin which is an insurance
company that happens to be one of
Israel's largest financial institutions
maybe a conflict of interest now the 30
million dollar deal was not public it
added new equity to ten Maryland
apartment buildings that Jared Kushner's
company controls so let's break down
what is and what is not with regard to
this thirty million dollars number one
I'm not saying nor is there evidence
that this was illegal okay
the law is actually really really narrow
on this and it doesn't seem that federal
ethics laws were violated by this it
doesn't appear nor am I suggesting that
Jared Kushner personally negotiated the
30 mm
dollar deal but Kushner knows he has a
stake in this business he knows that he
will make a bunch of money from this
deal so what I am saying is that this
could be the most biased and partial
group of people involved in the
negotiation of the israeli-palestinian
conflict to the extent that there's
actually any negotiation going on and
it's unclear that there is and to go
back to the very beginning the story
from Trump was we are going to fix the
israeli-palestinian conflict Jared
Kushner and David Friedman are going to
negotiate and the u.s. is going to be
the referee the arbiter of solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict to be an
arbiter or at least to be a potentially
effective arbiter there needs to be some
credibility to the idea that you're not
coming in as a biased party in the
negotiations it's like the referee in a
sporting event you need an unbiased
person calling the fouls we know that
Trump's ambassador David Friedman has
the position of wanting more settlements
by Israel in the disputed territories
it's an outrageous and extreme position
and it immediately signals him as not a
credible arbiter we know that Donald
Trump's decision to recognize Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel when in fact it
is still a disputed territory in the
conflict it's completely partial to the
Israelis and there could be no better
proof that the United States cannot be
an unbiased arbiter of peace talks in
the israeli-palestinian conflict and now
sort of the cherry on top we've learned
that Jared Kushner's family businesses
are profiting from doing business with a
major Israeli financial company and he
pat is going to be the guy who solves
the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
absolutely laughable and there have been
so many moments where we've wondered why
isn't just Jared Kushner resign right
because when he got caught lying for his
national security clear answer maybe
went like the Don Jr Natalya vessel
Disgaea news broke about that meeting at
Trump Tower he was involved in we
thought we thought you know he could
probably leave with some sort of grace
he could resign and because he's part of
the Trump family he could go to the
family business he could work with the
cushion family again now we realized
that it's not because he doesn't to be
embarrassed so much as that he's
profiting from this presidency he
doesn't need to leave the White House in
order to
working for the family business and we
we I mean another part of it might be
according to michael Wolf's book fire
and fury Ivanka and Kushner know the
deep you know what that they're in but
that they feel that they just can't
leave like in other words that because
of they're in completely completely
intractable positions in that Trump
administration and they have to be there
anyway if you're gonna wait around
hoping that there's consequences to
Jared Kushner for being involved in this
forget it right I mean former Vice
President Dick Cheney was directly
involved with Halliburton financially
which supplied the American military he
pushed for war in Iraq a war that
greatly enriched Halliburton there were
no consequences there's not going to be
any consequences here yeah Donald Trump
is pushing that tax plan that ended up
benefiting him greatly yeah there's just
never reproach
forget it if the idea is repercussion
repercussions and of course there's
always projection right is there
anything that Trump has accused Hillary
Clinton of doing that his administration
hasn't done he was accusing Hillary
Clinton of taking money from foreign
countries and foreign businesses and
here are Trump's own inner circle family
members doing the exact same thing it's
just politics as usual at warp speed
right that's what we're learning drain
the swamp was actually the opposite it
was filled as one send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david packard show we'll
take a quick break and be back with more
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is dawn
nori dawn thank you thank you don and
all of our new members in 2018 and all
of our longtime sustaining members some
of whom are in the their their entering
their eighth year as members in fact in
April we will have our first ever eighth
year member of the David Pakman show
which is truly truly incredible thanks
to everybody you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership you can also
make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month through patreon or petraea as I
heard someone call it online
that's a new one patreon.com slash a
David Pakman show ok I want to talk
about something that's been coming up
more and more I'm getting more and more
tweets and emails and comments not
calling me a Jew liar that the number of
those is relatively stable you'll be
pleased to know pat but more and more
tweets and emails and comments on
YouTube saying something along the lines
of hey David you should be thanking
Trump not complaining about him because
his presidency is helping shows like
yours this is absolutely and completely
correct at least the part that as I said
before the election I don't want Trump
to win I thought it would have been best
for the country that Trump not be
president but I'm aware that if Trump
had won I was aware that if Trump won
I'm aware that because Trump did win
it's way better for programs like the
David Pakman show there's no doubt about
that
but so then what right I should pretend
as though I support Trump's politics
because he's been good for our show
I should not criticize his atrocious
behavior and his lack of competence and
lack of fitness to serve as president
because yeah our audience has grown and
our membership has grown as people have
rallied around and organized against the
President of the United States and the
reason I'm talking about it today is
because I'm seeing it more and more it's
being said to me with a higher and
higher frequency David your show is
growing as
as it is because of Trump so lay off the
criticism of him what sense does that
make
right if there's one thing that I do
here it's that I call it the way I see
it no matter who's in office no matter
what is going on right it doesn't even
compute to me that because Trump being
president rather than Hillary being
president has helped us to grow my
coverage Trump should be adjusted in
that way I don't even understand what
argument it is that's being made if the
logic doesn't hold up because if you're
saying that our criticisms of Trump is
what is making the show be successful
wouldn't we want to continue that rather
than praise him if we started praising
him then I think our viewership would go
down well there's value to being in the
opposition right it's very different
doing a show it was very different doing
the David Pakman show under the George W
Bush administration than it was under
the Obama administration but that
doesn't mean that we didn't have endless
criticisms of President Obama but it's a
different type of criticism when you are
I guess sort of closer to the politics
of the person in the White House what
kind of program would it be if I said
well this Trump thing has been so good
for us that we should really lay off the
guy and kind of like pretend he's doing
good things know being in the opposition
to Trump is part of why people are
choosing to be solid you know to using
solidarity with us being in the
opposition has a sort of cachet that is
unique and beneficial but we've been
doing this too long to change the scope
of the show based on who's in office we
praise those in office when they deserve
praise no matter who they are we
criticize those in office when that's
what's called for period I even actually
started getting emails passing David the
reason you're saying it's better for
Democrats if Trump stays in isn't
because Mike Pence would be worse it's
because you need Trump so that your show
can is growing the show's been growing
for ten years right Donald Trump wasn't
president for most of that time I
believe that it could backfire for Trump
to leave genuinely I honestly believe
that the left might benefit from a
scandal-ridden Trump staying in the Oval
Office and yet every day we have more
evidence that the guy truly is in fits
so if the correct course of action is
removal then its removal but the idea
that I'm carefully crafting the
narrative of the show to have maximum
appeal at any given time if that was the
case I would have come up with dishonest
positions on other issues that would
have been more palpable to our audience
right uncircumcision a lot of our
audience doesn't like my position on
certain position if I wanted to take the
path of least resistance I would lie
about my position on circumcision which
is according to medical experts benefits
outweigh the risks I could have picked a
different position on the
israeli-palestinian conflict if I didn't
want to irritate some people on the left
or on Venezuela these are all areas
where if the the mo of this program was
due what is going to just be most
appealing to people then I would have
taken very different positions all along
if I've never done it before why would I
start with Trump so I find the criticism
to be totally bogus but you're right
we're doing way better because Trump won
and Hillary lost that's true
yeah we've been upfront about that I
remember when the tax plan was being
debated yeah we said that this could
actually be good for the David Pakman
show but we were opposed to it because
it's bad for the country no question
about it the pass-through income
provisions are good for anyone who owns
an S corporation like the David Pakman
show but morally I was opposed to it so
anyway give it a rest all right and
we're not changing the show and we
haven't changed the show because of any
of these whims I'm just doing the show
and doing every story the way I see it
there are some attempts being made to
pull me into some really childish
YouTube drama I don't even want to go
through it all with you because it's so
dumb and I don't even fully understand
it since I'm kind of busy producing a
show every weekday and I have limited
time to go through really long Twitter
threads but basically over the weekend a
youtuber had a debate that included
white nationalists Richard Spencer and
Karl Benjamin a youtuber who goes by the
name sargon of akkad and some others I
don't even know who write the debate I
think was like three or four hours long
it was on the channel of a guy named
Andrew wart ski or wash wash ski wore
ski and I somehow got tagged in two
tweets about the debate even though I
wasn't in the debate I don't know why I
was initially
tagged into it but I recognized that
name and revoir ski and I checked my
GMAT my email archives and I was
actually a few months ago offered $1500
to debate him on the internet and I
posted a tweet about that I just said oh
that's interesting I was actually
invited to be on a livestream Vivat
debate with and reward ski and I wore
ski and was offered $1500 to do it it
felt so sketchy in other words I didn't
necessarily believe I'd get paid that I
said sure money upfront and never heard
back I wonder if Richard Spencer Sargon
or others on that abortion of a debate
were offered the same it was completely
true right I was offered the $1500 I
found the debate to be an abortion
because it was just completely
uncontrolled and people talking over
each other and I don't know that
anything absolutely was was learned and
people went nuts
this Andrea Andrew wore ski guy did a
video filled with ad homonyms about me
there's a youtuber named something like
sticks in my hammer sticks end by hammer
something like that he did a video
making fun of my physical appearance
which is weird since he's got a peculiar
look himself but because that's not
really an argument right like attacking
my physical appearance is not an
argument and my tweet feed just filled
with drama from tons of people I don't
even know and I've had to start just
buting people by the dozens to clear out
my twitter twitter feed so anyway I have
a decision to make here I think it's all
total nonsense I don't care about these
people they're arguing about arguing and
doing nothing productive in terms of
debating actual ideas but I know Pat
that if I chose to get involved in this
drama that I could get a lot of
attention for the show right that
they've got saying all publicity is good
publicity if I just started responding
to every one of these people really
aggressively it would grant get a lot of
attention but is it worth it right like
I can only spend so much time in one day
doing all the things related to the show
that I could do social media being one
of them I get how clickbait media works
right it's much easier for me to just
argue with people about nothing online
than to well research a story for the
show but I don't think that our core
audience want there only so many hours
in the day they're only only as much
time in the
shows you and I think it has to do with
one of those things where you don't
really want to punch down too much I
mean there are people who make entire
video series and channels and playlists
dedicated entirely to just hating the
David Pakman right there's a it's a
cottage industry that has developed
around just making videos quote
debunking our clips anyway let me know
your thoughts for now I'm just muting
these people I I and and going along
with my day but if you think it would be
interesting to see me see me start
mixing it up on Twitter let me know but
my instinct is most people in the
audience would rather us talk about
politics and analyze issues and ideas I
told you this was coming in late 2017
and it is growing as of yesterday there
are thirty senators co-sponsoring a bill
to repeal the repeal of net neutrality
or I guess to reinstate Obama's net
neutrality provisions and those are
provisions that by and large are really
well liked by Americans it's the cable
companies and their lobbyists and big
corporations some big corporations only
who have been advocating for the removal
of those net neutrality provisions
lawmakers have 60 legislative days after
the FCC submits its regulations to
Congress to pass what's called the
congressional review act reversal the
Congressional review act allows Congress
to reverse the decision made by the FCC
if they do it within 60 legislative days
so it's great news that now there are 30
co-sponsors to this repeal of a repeal
of net neutrality in the Senate it means
that now it is going to get a full vote
on the Senate floor but I hate to be the
messenger of bad news it's still going
to fail because this is just Democrats
right the Republicans have the majority
they are not going to be able Democrats
are not going to be able to undo what
Trump's FCC has done even if the
Republican constituents want net
neutrality even if their constituents
will be hurt by Internet service
providers being able to do whatever the
hell they want it doesn't matter because
only Democrats are going to vote for
this and like we've said before this is
a political stunt but it might be the
type of political stunt that has some
you tell
in the 2018 midterms and in the 2020
election because there will now be a
record of senators who given the
opportunity to restore net neutrality
will have either abstained or voted not
to restore net neutrality that can be
used against them in upcoming campaigns
now there's lots of people in the
audience last time I mentioned this
effort who said David this is a great
thing no matter what and I agree it's
good but it could also be easily
deflated by Republicans who take the
small government approach where they say
listen
president Trump appointed Ajit PI former
Verizon lawyer the FCC has made its
decision we're not now going to go
against the will of that body so I I
genuinely don't know of what value it
will be in the 2018 and 2020 elections
what I do know is any publicity that can
be given to net neutrality I'm in favor
I'm actually a little bit more hopeful
than you are on really button because I
think you take those 49 Democrats right
then you add in John Thune from South
Dakota Republican who said that he's
actually in favor of some of the net
neutrality provisions and then maybe add
in some of those Republicans who are on
their way out like bob corker Jeff Flake
or any pain you could get something that
I don't see as so I just don't see I'm
gonna understand it's not gonna pass the
House president's not gonna sign it
absolutely absolutely so you know the
the bottom line is the FCC is a
disgustingly political organization it's
not there for the benefit of the public
it's been completely co-opted the term
regulatory capture could not apply to
any agency more than it applies to the
FCC former Verizon lawyer Ajit PI
appointed by Trump he now is running the
FCC so it's necessary for the public to
activate against the FCC rather than
being able to count on the FCC to defend
your interests and that is horrible and
it's a good reminder of do not fall for
both sides are the same yeah there are
many issues where there are no no sort
of practical operational meaningful
differences between Republicans and
Democrats one example is the sort of
implicit or tacit support for the status
quo of how politics are funded in the US
that's true Democrats and Republicans
very similar
but Democrats are all going to vote to
restore net neutrality and Republicans
are not with the exception of maybe the
couple that Pat is talking about
although I don't I don't really see it
happening there are important
differences between Republicans and
Democrats and this is one of them
interestingly on the state level
Nebraska is considering putting for
something forward that would protect
some of these net neutrality provisions
I saw that and even though it's
controlled by Republicans it still is a
good chance of passing but I think it's
because there on the state level and
thus much less corrupted than the
federal level that could be done in
other states but we're not yet seeing
any big hunger for that so it's great
that there's 30 co-sponsors sadly it's
not going to pass let's take a break we
will speak with Don Jeffries after the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm pleased to welcome to the program
today Don Jeffries who's author of the
new book survival of the richest which
looks at the issue of wealth disparity
and income inequality a topic we've been
talking about for a long time Don why do
you feel this is such an important issue
in the world today wealth disparity well
I think it's the most important issue in
America and the world when you have a
disparity of wealth we have which right
now we just recently learned that the
half of America 50% earns $27,000 a year
or less and we already knew that that
same half the bottom half of Americans
have less than 1% of the collected
wealth I don't think you can have a
first world economy or a first world
nation with that kind of growing to a
glowing disparity of wealth and and why
not in other words in practice what are
the negative repercussions of having
such wealth inequality well you have to
have people to be able to buy things to
purchase things and if you have to
understand such a dwindling safety net I
mean Republicans especially want to
eliminate what benefits are left out
there you have to have people be able to
survive we're not back in the old days
of being able foraging for your own food
and living off the land and so forth so
you have tons of people we also have
more people on government benefits right
now than we do have working so we have a
society we have to figure out how we're
going to handle this because you're
really going to consign people to lives
of poverty and death if they starve to
death or freeze to death and they don't
have housing or you're gonna have to
come up with some kind of universal
basic income or you're gonna have to
really be serious about bringing jobs
back and bringing factories back and
having full employment so let's take a
few of those pieces one at a time I have
not heard this data about you said
there's more people on government
benefits than working today what talk to
me about that a little bit yeah that was
that was widely disseminated though than
the last one out of six months or years
actually probably was when I was even
writing survival the richest it's just a
fact with all the obviously people on
Social Security there's lots of people
on Social Security disability
just various benefits getting Medicare
and Medicaid whatever and especially
with the baby boomers retired
increasingly you're gonna eventually
have not enough people working probably
to be able to support the baby boomer so
in other words you're in all retired
persons who receive Social Security
which of course they paid into now we're
rescuing those numbers understood let's
talk about that you mentioned the
bringing back of manufacturing jobs this
has been sort of a political football
for a long time and every good analysis
I've read really points to the the
reality that a lot of those jobs that
did at some point leave the u.s. aren't
coming back because increasingly they
don't exist anymore what do you think
about that
yeah I understand that's one of the
answers and that may be true and if that
is true that we can't bring back even a
sizable portion of those old jobs and we
have to look at our alternate especially
when you look at the artificial
technology that's coming in the the
robots are going to be you're taking who
knows how many millions of jobs so I
think that's when we have to look at
that I don't know Americans hate to hear
the universal basic income thing but you
have to come up with some way if the
jobs aren't there you have to have some
way for people to support themselves in
the book you talk about how a lot of
Americans don't really get how it is
that the system is rigged against them
and how there are a lot of mechanisms
that basically funnel or channel money
upward and there's a lot of people in
the US particularly on the American
right who claim to be against the
redistribution of wealth usually in the
form of using taxes on the rich to pay
for social welfare benefits for the not
rich but there's this other
redistribution that goes on all the time
that's an upward redistribution can you
talk about how that works yeah it's it's
everything I mean you look at the NFL
with all the problems they've had
recently all the all these stadiums that
have been built at taxpayer expense I
mean this is the greatest corporate
welfare imaginable where you have
billionaires it basically come crying to
the public and say you know I want you
to build my stadium for me that's the
the absolute opposite of us so-called
risk capitalism because they're not
taking any risk they're basically
threatening to move the team at the
public doesn't find ester Stadium and
the public invariably does even if they
don't want to because their
representatives are beholden to these
billionaires and not beholden to the
people in a way they're kind of
socializing the
risk of these projects while setting
themselves up to then claim the profits
as part of the entrepreneurial
capitalist system are they not yeah
socialism what works for them it works
right very wonderfully for them as I
point out in the book also they all
kinds of rich people get tons and tons
of freebies and celebrities up at farm
subsidies and things like that I have
the I have the you know we can't go into
it here but I have I have all those
statistics and names in my book and it's
the system is rigged for the rich and
and even the lower-class Americans don't
seem to mind that as much if you try to
talk about corporate welfare to them
they in durably talk about their
neighbor that's on food stamps or
somebody they saw at the store on food
stamps or how big their TB is that's
what they're concerned about mythical
wealth and queens and they don't care
about the billionaires not paying taxes
so part of being able to continue
rigging the system in this way involves
a PR campaign that as you are pointing
out puts the attention on the food stamp
recipient for example and a lot of
people in our audience probably are
familiar with you mentioned these
imaginary welfare queens the the
infamous Ronald Reagan story of a woman
with a Cadillac whatever right I don't
even remember the exact details we know
what we know it's been debunked talk a
little bit about how far back this
campaign goes influencing the average
American to sort of direct their ire and
anger at the imaginary welfare queen the
food stamp recipient whoever else how
far back does that go well I think it
began in earnest under Reagan did you
talk about with with the welfare queen
campaign in the right at that time began
to change and I wanted a little bit more
of this in hidden history in my previous
book where the right change from being
anti-communist and concerned about that
to being basically a nun and disciples
and a lot of this said we see this in
Paul Ryan especially today whose hero is
an ran a lot of these Republicans are
and Ayn Rand taught that greed is good
and one of her quotes was we have no
obligation to take care of our neighbors
and these people like Paul Ryan and
others are really beholden to her belief
so you can read the quotes I have in the
book about that but it's deadly
philosophy I mean parts of it are good
because you know individual liberty is
important but when you
individual liberty at the expense of the
whole where you just completely ignore
your neighbors which is what this
philosophy entails it's big it's kind of
a rugged individualism that might have
worked in the Wild West but it can't
work in our modern-day age unless you
want to go back to those days and again
you're gonna have people dead in the
streets and you're not gonna have a
first world country is that part of the
issue with the more sort of absolutist
libertarian ideals which when you read
about them framed in a way that's sort
of eloquent and articulate it can be
very very appealing but it's sort of
divorced from the realities of humans no
longer being like in a state of nature
and having society yeah and I have a lot
of a libertarian in me I mean I loved
Ron Paul and I loved the foreign policy
of libertarians I love the fact that
they the only people out there pretty
much you're emphasizing civil liberties
and allowing us to have our rights under
the Bill of Rights but you when you
carry it into the domestic arena they're
very unrealistic because they they act
as if you know it's an it's
insignificant that half the country
basically has nothing and I stress that
over and over again that's half the
country and with each new wave of
immigration that comes in it comes in at
the bottom level so that those people
entering the country are desperately
poor and so they're making that bottom
fifty percent figure grow and grow
because they're obviously not adding any
wealth of the country and that group
already has no wealth so you have to be
able to distribute that that wealth a
little bit at least a little bit more
fairly and we see back into the Golden
Age what we consider the Golden Age of
America like the 1950s the top tax rate
was ninety percent I don't want to
necessarily go back to that but that's
when things seemed to rent and run more
smoothly because the rich at that time
still had all their loopholes and plenty
that didn't play taxes but it things
were distributed more fairly and you
didn't have the CEO worker disparity of
income that we have now back then they
weren't CEOs there were presidents of
the companies many times they had
founded the country company so they had
a vested stake and it an interest in it
and they also had more civic pride and
they cared a little bit more about how
things ran outside of their own profit
margins and their own size of their
bonuses how would you fix this issue
because very often you will get some
buy-in when people hear you sort of
identify the
problem and let's say we get buying that
that we all agree yet this is a problem
there's a lot of negative externalities
to such significant income and wealth
inequality we kind of agree on that
there will be a significant contingent
that is opposed to just what they would
call unreasonable levels of Taxation in
order to redistribute so is taxation one
of the paths that you would identify is
it V path how do you fix the problem
well I'm a Huey Long disable is you know
I have a whole chapter devoted to Huey
Long in the book and I really would go
try to go back to his share of the
wealth program which people don't
realized they called him a communist and
so forth the first million dollars of
income and this is in the 1930s it
should be like twelve million now would
not have been taxed so basically no one
but the 1% of the 1% win that's people
don't realize how much wealth is
concentrated at the top we don't even
know because we don't how much wealth
exactly is in these tax-free foundations
I would go after that the way Huey long
did I would also follow the
recommendations at the grace Commission
in the 1980s which found that fully
one-third of all government spending is
completely wasted so we could cut taxes
by one-third and spending by one-third
at least it's probably more waste by now
in the ensuing years it without without
anyone you know how can anybody possibly
eject to that I would means test Social
Security I would start test taxing all
Social Security income most people won't
realize they're regressive Social
Security tax well let's talk about that
one though if we can done because so I
think that there when it comes to Social
Security there's a number of different
sort of mathematical problems we can
identify and I think that the idea of
lifting or removing the cap so for
people who don't know and you'll correct
me if I'm wrong it's around a hundred
you pay Social Security tax on the first
hundred and twenty thousand or so of
income per year is that roughly the
number 123 that's right something along
those lines anything you weren't beyond
that you no longer pay into Social
Security but of course the benefits that
you're going to get out out of Social
Security upon retirement also reach a
cap so one way to have a huge influx of
money into the Social Security system
would be to double triple quadruple or
even eliminate that cap altogether now I
would be up for discussing that but I
think if you do that
it's going to be very difficult to also
argue for means-testing social security
particularly when the benefits are not
particularly extravagant I think if you
do one which I agree with I don't know
about the means-testing part well I mean
either would be great I'd like to that
both but Ross Perot back in 1992 tried
to test fly the idea of voluntary means
testing as he said I don't need Social
Security and the AARP and the the
lobbies typical lobby shot him down so I
think at the very least the people that
are conscious all these people like
Warren Buffett that claim you know tax
me more whatever that at least publicly
they would have to say I don't need
Social Security Bill Gates and so forth
so I think if you again there's no
reason for those people to have Social
Security I agree means testing it it's a
very extreme measure but you know this
this is what happened we go back to the
days of LBJ when they first started
dipping into the Social Security Fund it
was supposed to be a separate fund and
then it really went overboard during the
Reagan years the great tax cutter
Texican tax cut taxes for the top one
percent but he raised Social Security
taxes dramatically and he started taxing
Social Security benefits that was it's
ironic that the great tax cutter was the
one who decided to double tax people on
Social Security and we still have that
system today so there's all these things
could be rolled back and it's not going
to be an easy fix overnight I realize a
Huey Long type fix is probably
impractical but people just kind of roll
your eyes when you say that but we need
something with it we need something to
try to get the wealth out spread out to
the great mass of people and you have to
go where the wealth is so any any kind
of conventional tax system that the
Democrats would devise is not going to
work because you have that's why Huey
Long was so dangerous to people because
he wasn't like an FDR and LBJ or Bill
Clinton or Barack Obama he wanted to go
right after the absolute top 1% and
that's why if you look at the quotes
about him today the left can't stand him
when he should have been there ideal
hero but he wasn't because he he wasn't
playing this game or creating a big
bureaucracy in middlemen and so forth
and we could see the the war on poverty
if it had actually been waged correctly
the way obj was going to wage it would
have been won and not lost Duran eclis
as it has been done the book is
fascinating it's called survive
full of the richest we've been speaking
with the book's author Don Jeffries
thanks so much for talking to us thanks
for having the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
it's been a rough go for president
Donald Trump with the football world he
first was pushing against the totally
valid expressions of free speech that
were taking place when NFL football
players were kneeling or doing other
types of protests during the national
anthems before games a couple months ago
and now it's carrying over into the
college football world yesterday was the
college football playoff National
Championship game between Alabama and
Georgia Alabama ultimately defeated
Georgia twenty six to twenty three and
one of Alabama's players although it's
not a hundred percent sure who was
caught on camera
yelling F Trump as the players went out
onto the field it just so happens Donald
Trump was at this game but more on that
later here comes the Alabama team and
initially it was alleged that it was
beau Scarborough who yelled although he
has since denied that it was him and
here's what was heard during the very
very riled up jog out to the field
right let's play it once more for people
again I'm not going to say exactly what
he said the we are considering these
fleeting expletives that we hope mercy
will be taken upon us for broadcasting
but here's one more time what it was
that was said
so immediately all the normal stuff you
would expect started right some people
saying hey this is free speech period no
other discussion to be had others saying
this is a thug no doubt racial overtones
there as we're very acquainted with
others saying this player whoever it was
was disrespectful to the office of the
presidency if not to Trump himself yet
other people saying that he was a poor
representative of the University of
Alabama and again we I guess we pat we
don't really know who did this that the
player accused with was beau Scarborough
but he's denying that it was him who
said it he denies it but obviously he
could face some retribution from the
school yeah it hurt his draft potential
during the NFL if he was to go there
yeah I don't know ultimately what the
truth is but I actually don't know how
anyone on the side of the trumpet's can
credibly criticise this when it is quite
literally locker room talk right
remember when it's so funny when Trump
talked about grab him by the
you-know-what it happened on a tour bus
before filming a TV show and I think Los
Angeles was nothing and Trump said oh
that was locker room talk that was a
stretch then this was a football player
literally exiting a locker room before a
football game if anything has ever been
locker room talk it's this Bo
Scarborough or whoever it was yelling F
Trump anyway I hope the headlines
tomorrow aren't Bo Scarborough receives
multiple death threats as a result of
what he said yeah I'm worried that
Donald Trump will confuse Bo Scarborough
with Joe Scarborough maybe I call him
like crazy Bo yeah he thinks this is the
guy who was there when Mika was beating
a bleeding badly
bad facelift or whatever it was that
President Trump said about her
interesting things happening in Alabama
dope though a couple of weeks ago they
elect a Democrat to the Senate and now
this but seriously I'm not offended by
this at all whether you care or not what
a football player or a celebrity or an
actor thinks about the president that's
one thing I genuinely don't really care
but it is absolutely fine to use
whatever venue you have to express your
opinions now it might have consequences
right freedom of speech is not freedom
from the consequences of that speech and
when a football player or an actor
whoever chooses to go political people
might not support them they they might
not buy tickets to the sporting event or
buy a ticket to the movie or whatever
but how can anyone really be offended by
this yeah I'm sure he wasn't thinking
about all that when he said that comment
but you probably didn't think that it
was gonna be captured on television
either maybe not yeah who knows let's
now get to the other story from the
Alabama Georgia football game involving
Donald Trump I know this is a weird
thing to be talking about but the video
evidence is what's making me ask this
question does Donald Trump know the
words to the United States national
anthem does the patriotic 71 year old
American Donald Trump who has been
patriotically singing the national
anthem his whole life like any good
Republican would do does he know the
words
did he ever or has he forgotten them and
as I mentioned earlier Trump was at the
college football championship game last
night between Alabama and Georgia one
highlight from the game was actually
before the game when an Alabama player
possibly both scarborough yelled f trump
but another highlight took place before
the game during the singing of the
national anthem Trump went out on the
field flanked by military service
members of course and it appeared that
for long stretches of the national
anthem he didn't know the words he sort
of seemed to be wanting to sing along
I'm gonna play the video for you if
you're listening I'll describe to you
what it is that we're seeing and if
you're watching with me you'll see that
there are periods where Trump just
generally looks confused and stopped
singing altogether kind of unsure what
to say let's take a look at a little bit
of this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you view those couple words yeah that
was a good stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's appearing for him
okay my question is alright in the
context of football
if kneeling during the national anthem
is disgrace or skirt graceful if being
off the field during the national anthem
is disrespectful
if protesting during the anthem in any
way makes you a son-of-a-bitch as Donald
Trump once said what is this now I want
to be clear Pat I don't actually think
this is that big of a deal I doubt I
could tell you the lyrics to the full
national anthem I might come close I
couldn't tell you the the the words to
the Argentinian national anthem I don't
think it's a big deal but in Trump's
world by his internal logic that he's
established respecting the anthem is of
paramount importance if Obama had done
this and seemed to flub the words it
would be 24/7 on right-wing media
foreigner non citizen Obama bungles
anthem lyrics but when it's Trump I
guess it doesn't matter anyway yeah so
then Trump doesn't have the grounds to
criticize others and there's no chance
that he knows what the star-spangled
banner is about - could he name the war
that the song was made for probably not
I think that's actually a more
interesting question which is for all
the people who hold the national anthem
in a sort of way the same sort of way
they hold the Constitution almost like
some kind of sacred text what's more
important knowing the words or actually
understanding the meaning and context in
which it was written I would argue the
latter but bottom line I don't think
that this is hugely important but it
does point to two items of interest
number one
Trump's ongoing hypocrisy when it comes
to what's okay for others to do versus
what it's okay for him to do and number
two when it comes to the cognitive
decline question did he know the words
through the national anthem at one point
and since has forgotten them which would
not exactly bolster the framework of a
very very stable genius maybe that part
of the song was outside of his vocal
range you know that could be yeah
because I
he's a baritone right oh sure I have no
idea we've got a voicemail number two
one nine to david p here's a voicemail
that came in let's take a listen to it
hey David my name is Kelly I am calling
from Indiana it's my first time calling
but I've been listening to you for a
while okay I've recently heard that you
went on a trip to Indiana and I just
want to let you know not ever
buddy from Indiana is like that there
are I would say a few progressives that
aren't trumpet in Indiana so yeah just
wanted to clarify
Indiana's Matt and all that state thank
you right no I knew that I did meet one
person who wasn't the trumpet during my
trip in Indiana out of about 50 or 60
but I know that Indianapolis actually is
comparatively speaking relative to the
rest of the state there's a lot of lefty
stuff going on in Indiana yes hashtag
not all indianians not all isn't it
Indiana's I like that better indianians
and I like how she says there there are
a few reasonable people yeah out of you
know like the millions that live in
Indiana overall no I believe it I
believe it there are absolutely
reasonable people in the great state of
Indiana Mike Pence not one of those
people great bonus show for you today
david pakman.com slash membership to get
access patreon.com slash david pakman
show will also get you access
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]